[Applause]
so who are you oh so who are you
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how hilly dum opening I am
stupidly proud of it okay so let's talk
about uh I was gonna say big spoilers
except I don't think there's any way for
me to even like title this without it
being some kind of spoiler and I'd be a
little bit more reticent to do that
except the bbbc official Doctor Who
friggin channel the day after part 1 of
spy fall aired put up a video that both
the title and the thumbnail were massive
spoilers for this so here we go look the
Masters back and we have a whole new one
and I see a lot of questions getting
asked about who is this the master where
does he fit in the masters timeline does
he follow after Missy if so how because
with what happened to Missy that should
be the end of the masters timeline if he
does follow after Missy does that mean
that they have completely negated the
arc that Missy went through for that if
he doesn't come in after Missy then
we're in the masters timeline does he
fit now before I actually dig into this
I just be upfront about something
personally I don't really care now like
I don't want to be dismissive about that
I understand lots of fans do care but
for me I don't need an answer to that
the Masters back cool awesome I kind of
take that as a given that it was going
to happen now if they ever offer
specifics I will scrutinize them to see
if they make sense but I'm kind of weird
like that often times with me you're
better off going for a minimal
explanation than a detailed one because
whatever details you give me I will
scrutinize often though not always
often if you give me fewer details I'll
be more okay with that because I have
less to pick apart and my brain just
kind of icicles oh just roll with it
master's back cool but accepting that
many people do care and it is kind of an
interesting question to address and to
think about I don't have the secret
answer but let's look at the
possibilities and let's discuss the
options here
now the obvious assumption is that this
master follows on from Missy and that's
not an unfair assumption to make we have
pretty much always seen the master so
far as we know in chronological order of
his incarnations and same with the
doctor for that matter yes there's the
multi doctor stories that cross over but
we've been following you know one one
that follows after the other you know
borrowing again multi the one multi
master story that actually happened in
the show so that's the obvious
assumption but there's a couple of
things about that that I'm not gonna say
I'm necessarily problems but are
definitely hangups and have some people
a little bit iffy about that idea
the first is the way Missy died it
really was heavily implied that the
master should not be able to regenerate
again after that now does that mean that
the master can't of course it doesn't
the master wasn't supposed to be able to
come back at the end of last of the
Timelords
either but you know I mean it was
obviously they were going to they
planted the ring or whatever but like
they didn't know how they were gonna do
it yet but there's always a way around
that but as it stands right now that
shouldn't happen and the other thing is
and this seems to be the bigger hang-up
for people especially people who like
Missy which I do though again this isn't
as big a hang-up for me personally I'll
get to by in a second there is the issue
of Missy basically had an arc of finding
her friendship with the doctor again now
she didn't sudden
become a good person she was still kind
of terrible which is part of why she was
still awesome but you know she she
softened she was prepared to side with
him when the chips were down and to have
the master going back to these big
elaborate plans to take over to dominate
and also to kill the doctor kind of fly
in the face of that and I understand
that argument but at the same time I was
just speaking personally I don't
consider that to be a disqualifying
factor just because the master is
allowed to have a little bit of a
personality reset the same way the
doctor does actually I'd say the master
has gone through a much more rigidly
defined personality than the doctor has
in terms of regeneration overall
regeneration so you know reconnecting
back to something from earlier it's not
completely out of the question if for
whatever reason a regeneration following
Missy did kick off that said while I do
feel that is a viable explanation it's
also a little bit of a cop-out
and I think what again while it may not
bother me especially personally it's
probably not the direction that they
should ever go if they do decide to
confirm exactly where the new Matt I'm
just probably gonna refer to him as Oh
at least for the purposes of this video
to distinguish him from the others so
we've got you know him coming in after
Missy I think just is gonna just take a
lot of people off and you don't have to
cuz here's the fun thing about the
master we don't know every regeneration
of the master we know every regeneration
of the doctor there were at times
previous the possibility that the first
doctor William Hartnell's doctor was not
in fact his first incarnation that's
pretty much shot down at this point
because of
you know this the things really getting
nailed down in terms of how many were
generations that have been as locked
down in time of the doctor so we've seen
every incarnation of the doctor we
haven't seen every incarnation of the
master in fact we're missing a lot so
who have we seen so far we've seen Roger
Delgado
now it's debatable whether you want to
count the crispy master as a separate
incarnation or not because it that is
possibly still technically the same
incarnation just a much much closer to
death but for the sake of counting sure
but for right now we'll count that we
know that transition directly into the
Anthony Ainley doctor because that was
the form that took over Treme's so we've
got now at most three and this one did
not necessarily lead into that one and
then from tree must we have the the Eric
Roberts master and we don't know what
incarnation now again we didn't see that
to that so we got more gap here where it
could have been anything and then we've
got we've got the war master which was
Derek Jacobi met in Utopia gotten filled
out in some big finish a bit but we know
that the master was basically
resurrected by the Time Lords and given
a whole new regeneration cycle remember
that so for more master to John Simm we
know that one direct and then for John
Simm to Missy question mark so
in I I went back and we watched it in
world and no sorry not world that I've
had I'm in the doctor falls it is
implied that John Simm is probably the
immediate preceding incarnation before
Missy but that's not confirmed that's
not 100% we don't know that for certain
so we've got a lot again we also don't
even know of where the Roger Delgado
master was the first master so we've got
a lot of gaps in here where Oh could
slot in and like I said it's not just a
matter of fitting in between some there
could have been multiple regenerations
in between any number of these just
because as I said the master actually
got a whole new regeneration cycle so
minimum then if you got a whole new
regeneration cycle that's thirteen
incarnations reach that's minimum
twenty-six versions of the master and we
have currently accounted for if we count
oh eight maximum assuming that the
crispy one is not the actually the same
one as Roger Delgado we've got eight
there's a lot there's a lot of slots for
him to fit in now that being said
there's still probably some eliminations
that we can do it's very unlikely that
he is in the early half of the master's
life just because the amount of stuff
that he is seeing and countering dealing
with it doesn't quite line up the idea
that somebody say earlier than Delgado
would be the case and also more than
that Oh has to be an incarnation that
the master has not met the doctor in
before because he sneaks in and the
doctor doesn't recognize him so whatever
incarnation of the master it is it can't
be one that the doctor encountered
before which also makes pre Delgado less
likely now we don't know for a fact that
every incarnation of the master and the
doctor like hung out and did stuff
together but
given the nature of their friendship
that's not a huge leap it's not a given
it's not a lockdown but again the the
idea of it being from prior to that
especially with something like the you
know you can mention the tissue
compressor thing which was something the
older master used and I think some
people are even sort of thinking maybe
that's an indication that he's in
earlier incarnation he seems to be
treating it like a throwback though at
least to my read on it and the other
thing is I don't especially with what we
saw in spy fall apart - I don't think
that it makes any sense for him to be
any earlier than John Simm be cut and so
I'm not gonna break down each individual
gap they're going up leading up to him
because if what he said was accurate in
terms of like he wrecked Gallifrey then
it wouldn't make a ton of sense if he is
pre John Simm for John Simm to have the
reaction that he does when the doctor
tells him Gallifrey is gone so because
when he hears that he's like happened
Gallifrey be gone you know he heeds he
has disbelief about that and it doesn't
make sense if like he himself kind of
took a torch to the place prior to the
events of the Johnson master and the
David Tennant doctor so I think just
based on that most likely it is the
cleanest fit for him to come in between
John Simm and Missy that would spare
Missy's arc from you know that doesn't
get reversed they don't have to account
for
you know how more regenerations after
Missy happened honestly they could have
13 more incarnating more than that they
could have like they could they could
have like 18 more incarnations of the
master and not and they could all
theoretically slot between
Zinnemann Missy and not have to ever
address nah it just have Missy be the
end they could actually do that I'll be
curious to see if they ever do answer
definitively where this version of the
master falls where old lands because I
almost kind of thing is in their best
interest to not and just leave us
squirming on the hook and come up with a
head cannon that works best for us um
cuz I mean that that's basically what
I'm gonna do anyway but not everyone's
like me some people really want to know
so given that what are your thoughts
this new master where does he fit are
you liking him enjoying him not like you
I think he's pretty good so far
want to see more so whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a bunch of
stuff to do you know the things likes
and subscribes and ring the bell
it does it does stuff I think I don't
know
I've also got a patreon if you want to
help me out and yeah that would that
would help and other stuff besides links
in the description you don't have to do
any of it though cuz at the end of the
day you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]